what the [__] do you do when you're
depressed and you don't know what the
[__] is going on with your life I'm 23
I'm about to graduate
all these kind of good things are
happening around me but man I've been
more depressed with my life and I've
seen you like on this week and like this
weekend and all that [__] and I saw you
were going through a hard pass now and I
was going through a hard passion I just
kind of want to hear you know what do
you do to kind of see the brightness
when he's standing in the dark man be
well
thanks Ryan I appreciate that man
um that's you know it's a good question
what do you do you know I'm not I'm not
trying to get all philosophical what I
do uh in the past I didn't do anything
man I'll tell you that I made some poor
choices I would lay in my bed
I would do masturbation
you know I would do just masturbation
until I didn't even have any feelings I
would almost just beat my feelings out
of my body uh via masturbation you know
and I started masturbation when I was
young and
uh and it persisted man even and that's
another thing about you know no man ever
told me anything about masturbation man
you know I mean when my father was young
he had he's probably on horses and who
knows what the [__] they were doing you
know I don't even if they had
masturbation then uh
and my brother was gone he wasn't there
so I learned it you know by watching
some pornography videos and uh some boy
beat me up at the library one time and
showed me a bunch of pictures of uh
Cooter that's what he called it and he
would that boy was beating me and making
me look at this look at these pictures
of Cooter that he had that were all
jacked up and in men
probably just looked like they've been
looked at so many times it was nasty
but what do I do man I try to find some
Faith these days I try to have faith
you know that things will be okay
I mean it's it's hard to tell a guy I
mean you're in college you're going
through those you know there's a lot
going on in your life I bet it's busy
you know your your future probably seems
immense your possibilities probably seem
endless
uh but also it's probably scary if
you're graduating you're getting out of
college I'll just tell you this man you
got time to make some poor choices
so even if whatever you're choosing
doesn't end up being phenomenal
you can [__] up dude you could start a
bakery bro you could start a bait you
could do French Breads and
you know baguettes and whatever and [__]
that whole industry up dude you could
burn the bakery down and try to get
insurance money go to jail for that for
eight years
you get out you're only 31.
you could then join the service get out
of that and you're only 35.
and you still can do it you know so you
have time to kill man so I just wouldn't
be so hard on yourself
and take a step back
and sometimes when you're in your
problems you can't see that the reality
of things
is that things are okay
you know sometimes you're just so caught
up like you got to do this and you got
to do that sometimes the best thing to
do is nothing
and just realize that
they that
by not doing anything you're going to be
okay you know take care of whatever your
basic needs are
and just relax man you know relax
especially if you're in college man they
got you know Hot Leg running around and
you could do
you know you could experiment and do
homosexuality you could do whatever you
want
and uh and whatever it is you'll be able
to you know get through it or get past
it
um because time will heal everything man
I promise you that dude uh time will
hear heal everything so I'd say look at
the reality bud I would say this look at
the reality of things in the big scheme
of things
it's not going to be that overwhelming
when I think back about college the only
thing I really remember is
that I wish I would have had more fun
that I wish I wouldn't have worried so
much about this or that you know about
the tests and about the
you know um what people thought of me
and I just wish I'd had a good time I
wish I had more pictures from College of
me having a blast bro that's what I wish
so if I had any guidance there or
thoughts or suggestions I would say take
it easy take a step back if [__] feels
dark find a mentor you know find us find
a you know somebody already graduated
and talked to them talk to talk to
somebody don't go It Alone you know find
you another man and get out there and
put your feelings out there
you know you can't be afraid to put your
feelings out there dude
uh that boy Thunder's Daddy he used to
when I would miss the school bus his dad
would give me a ride to school
and he would even help me with my
spelling words and he used to smoke uh
Marlboro cigarettes and he would blow
the cigarette smoke at me
while I was trying to recite my spelling
and it's hard his spelling is kind of
hard enough I did well in it but
spelling
when you got smoke coming at you and in
your eyes and everything even harder
you know you're trying to spell their
when you're trying to spell
just being attacked by secondhand smoke
that's a real
I mean that's some [__] straight up
Wyatt Earp I mean you're the Wyatt Earp
of consonants syllables at that point so
um but I remember sometimes I would
share with him what was going on because
even if it was just a few minutes in a
car together that was another man around
that I could reach out to for support
so that's what I would say man take it
easy look at the reality of the
situation don't get caught in them in
the in the minutia that's right in front
of you look at the big picture big
picture you're finishing college man
that's a huge achievement big picture is
you could [__] up you could do your
bakery and [__] it up and still be fine
um you could do law school medical you
could you got time bud so don't get too
overwhelmed take your time take it easy
man that's what I would say
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one